romrod mit globetrotter darm spezialist
für mohrs schmiederad globetrotter
punktzahl
[Musik]
ich bin immer unterwegs in einem
sammeltaxi von mandala nachbarn der
mystischen pagoden statt
unsere reise begann in kunming in
südchina die ort bouveret führte uns bis
nach burma nach mandala ist heute begann
mein erstes etappenziel
[Musik]
samu taxis gehören zu den beliebtesten
fortbewegungsmittel thomas sie sind
flexibel günstig aber auch unberechenbar
hallo
zuzug aus anderen regionen und ich muss
jetzt raus in den regen die lieferung
richtig damals waren ein händler bietet
bethel müsse für umgerechnet 10 rappen
sie sind als aufputschmittel beliebt ich
mache einen selbstversuch und nun ich
nehme sie so in den mund und kaut neuer
wirklich ori zum wachbleiben
summer barriere wird meistens elter
straße beratungsstellen vor ort und
damit noch stärker fahrt von news.de
mittel
so und dann einfach gehört aber mit
spürt schon den kopf das ist gut
die sache
nach diesem kleinen experiment selbst
soll ich meine reise fort auf einem
ungewöhnlichen gefährt
[Musik]
wir sind die nacht hinein sind wir
unterwegs
[Musik]
burma hat viele magische orte organ ist
einer davon
am schönsten ist es hier mitten in der
steppe bei seinen aufgaben
das pagoden feld erstreckt sich über 40
quadratkilometer
es ist eine der größten archäologischen
stätten asiens vor knapp 1000 jahren war
begann die hauptstadt des ersten
burmesischen reiches damals wurden
tausende von pagoden und tempel
errichtet bis heute spenden einheimische
für den bau von pagoden um ihr karma zu
verbessern weil die pagoden oft nicht
originalgetreu renoviert werden gehört
dass welt bis heute nicht zur unesco
weltkulturerbe
ballonfahrer film arbeitet seit 15
jahren in baghana nur die monsun zeit
verbringt der engländer jeweils in
seiner heimat afghanistan einheimische
spirituell ein ganz besonderer
auch für uns ballonfahrer wir können mit
dem ballon ganz nah über die pagoden
stimmen für uns ist dies einer der
schönsten orte unseres planeten
[Musik]
ich will deine hand halten beim
einschlafen und das erste was ich am
morgen sehen bist du
chinesen sind nicht aus große romantiker
bekannt aber schon heute scheint eine
ausnahme
als er um die hand seiner angebeteten
anhält bleibt kein auge trocken
[Applaus]
[Musik]
für die kamera das toll
mit der violinistin und dem anwalt stoße
ich auf ihr glück grad
alle die nachbarn kommen lassen sie von
der mystik des ortes verführen wir
lassen wagen hinter uns um reisen zum
ähnlich
danach geht es weiter zur ehemaligen
hauptstadt rangun
[Musik]
der inder sie eine der beliebtesten
touristen destination burmas es ist der
zweitgrößte süßwassersee des landes in
diesen stelzen häusern leben die inter
die menschen vom see
er ernährt 70.000 von ihnen die einbahn
fischer mit ihrer speziellen
rudertechnik sind ein beliebtes
fotosujet wie idyllisch das leben für
die fischer wirklich ist will ich bei
einer familie aus dem dorf keiner
erleben
die sechsköpfige familie muss von dem
leben was der see her gibt
die unverheiratete tankt er gehört zur
familie sowie cousine die zu besuch ist
fahren datei wie sein jüngster der
alltag der familie ist hart für ihre
kinder erhofft sich mutter die ein
leichteres leben
sie sollen eine gute ausbildung erhalten
damit sie es besser haben
die tochter kommt nun in die achte
klasse
dafür muss ich die schule in einem
anderen dorf besiegt das wird sehr teuer
die familie lebt von der hand in den
mund aber es ist selbstverständlich mit
großzügigen zu bewerten natürlich mit
frischen fisch ich hätte gerne bei der
fischer familie übernachtet aber die
regierung verbietet das an den einnahmen
der touristen hotels verdient sie mit
sie sagen sie fliegen heute nicht viele
fische nur wenige ja sehr wenige in der
abenddämmerung macht sich teil wen
bereit für den nächtlichen fischfang die
frauen bringen proviant und eine dicke
jacke
wenn nachts kann es auf den sehr
empfindlich kühl werden
[Musik]
teil werden fährt an den schwimmenden
gärten vorbei
sie bestehe dass erdigen schlick und was
doch jahrzehnten ein fruchtbarer
nährboden für salat und tomaten jüngeren
pestizide verbessern die ernte
verschmutzen aber auch denn sie
[Musik]
mein großvater brachte noch um die 20
kilo fisch pro tag nach hause
heute fange ich gerade mal zwischen zwei
und vier
wegen des klimawandels hat sich der
wasserspiegel gesenkt zwei wien verdient
umgerechnet zwischen drei und fünf
franken am tag ein boot kostet um die
300 franken und die vielen touristen
erschweren sein leben zusätzlich sagt er
die da die brauche ich nicht zum fischen
die vielen touristenboote zerstören
meine netze es hat viel zu viele davon
[Applaus]
[Musik]
am nächsten worten die karge ausbeute
einer langen nacht
wir uns in die vielen touristen alle
anderen verdienen viel geld mit ihnen
egal wo man regierung profitiert vor
allem natürlich die hotelbesitzer was
machen sie nur probleme hilft ihrem land
wo sie kann
für die familie und die katze müssen ein
paar fisch erreichen
den rest wird dorian dorf verkaufen oder
umsatz konservieren
[Musik]
auf der anderen seeseite boomt der
tourismus die inters müssen sich mit den
folgen der rasanten entwicklung
auseinandersetzen
hier prallen die interessen der
einheimischen und der investoren
aufeinander
seit 2010 werden hier hotelanlagen
gebaut reicht dann eben 30 bungalow am
bungalow
früher waren hier überall reisfelder
heute gibt es gerade noch eines es
gehört sein will die regierung
enteignete sie und nahm ihr den größten
teil des landes weg herr weber sie haben
sie jemals kompensationszahlungen
bekommen
noch vor zehn jahren nahmen sie uns das
land einfach wenn aber die bevölkerung
protestiert und forderte
kompensationszahlung bezahlte die
regierung für reisfelder umgerechnet 50
rappen pro quadratmeter für die anderen
felder 25 rappen bauern die sich gegen
die enteignung werten wurden bedroht und
vorübergehend inhaftiert aber davon wie
sie es an wie nie einschüchtern
woher nehmen sie den mut es ist mein
eigentum
niemand darf mir das land stehlen es
geht nicht nur mir sondern im ganzen
dorf da drüben dürfen wir nicht einmal
mehr durch sie haben einen zaun richtig
wie soll das weitergehen
wir leiden davon sollen wir leben wenn
nicht vom eis
[Musik]
der tourismus bringt den inter viele
probleme aber einige profitieren auch
davon in einer der großen hotelanlagen
werde ich vom sohn des fischers begrüßt
er arbeitet hier aus hotelbau er hilft
den touristen sich zurechtzufinden
wir haben eine mini war der regen haben
wir die klimaanlage seien zensierung
anrufen wollen wählen sie die 0 verdient
umgerechnet knapp 50 franken im monat
dazu kommen kostenlos und trinken und
dann bringen die gäste in ihrer zimmer
und erkläre ihnen die 1 rete gas
ja das ist alles das ich verabschiede
mich von soja und den inter und denke
dass hier wohl in wenigen jahren alles
ganz anders aussehen wird
[Musik]
die reise führt mich weiter in die vier
millionen stadt yang gon
die ehemalige hauptstadt rangun
sind sie frei können sie wieder gedreht
[Musik]
shell der taxifahrer zeit mir die stadt
dies hat der öffnung buam aus 2011
rasant verändert hat die straßen sind
verstopft
häufig ist kein durchkommen mehr überall
häuser aus der kolonialzeit
die meisten sind vom zerfall bedroht
aber renovieren ist kostspielig neue
häuser versprechen höheren profit
[Musik]
die öffnung burmas lockt seit 2011
internationale investoren an die boten
und liegenschafts preise stiegen in
rekordhöhe
eine eigentliche goldgräberstimmung
überhitzte den immobilienmarkt
mittlerweile sind die investoren
realistischer geworden
sie haben gemerkt dass es nicht so
einfach ist schnellen profit zu machen
stelle fährt nicht zum haus der
friedensnobelpreisträgerin aung san suu
kyi der gewaltlosen kämpferin für
demokratie am eingangstor ein bild ihres
berühmten vaters general aung san
hier ist auch der sitz der rally der
national league for democracy hinter
diesen mauern verbrachte anfang sotschi
15 jahre hausarrest und wurde zur ikone
und zum popstar seit dem erdrutsch der
nld vor drei jahren sitzt sie im
parlament für das präsidentenamt darf
die 70 jährige bei den bevorstehenden
wahlen nicht kandidieren
eine klausel im gesetz verbietet das
auch shell kämpft seit jahrzehnten für
mehr demokratie und bürgerrechte
dafür saß er mehrmals im gefängnis
insgesamt 14 jahre
dieser park nahe der universität der
heute so friedlich aussieht war ein
politischer brennpunkt 1988 wurde hier
gegen die wirtschaftspolitik des
militärregimes demonstriert wie viele
protestierten hier so um die 1000
studenten also 1000 studenten die ganze
straße war voll und dann kam die polizei
sie schlugen auf die demonstranten ein
und die polizei verhaftete die studentin
und steckte sie ins gefängnis
ich war im haus meines freundes wir
trafen uns heimlich bei ihr um eine
weitere demonstration zu planen
als militärisch im griff mit äußerster
brutalität durch tausende wurden getötet
die regierung sprach lediglich von ein
paar hundert schell wurde im gefängnis
gefoltert
während der befragung schlugen sie mich
mit einem harten gegenstand
ich weiß nicht womit er spürte dass mein
mund voll blut wurde
modul 1 realisierte ich noch nicht dass
sie meine vorderzähne ausgeschlagen
es war während der einvernahme diese
vier tage waren die hölle
[Musik]
auch bei der shwedagon pagode wurde
geschichte geschrieben
2007 demonstrieren hier mönche gegen
drastische preiserhöhungen beim
treibstoff ihr protest weitete sich
schnell aus und richtete sich gegen das
herrschende militärregime die sogenannte
safran revolution begann sie kommen
jeden tag hierher ja jeden tag eine
ganze woche lang und wie viele mönche
waren dabei so um die 3000 sie kamen von
überall auch von klöstern außerhalb
janko wir fingen sie an zu diskutieren
ja es waren über 10.000 menschen wie
zusammen demonstrierten
auch dieser aufstand wurde blutig
niedergeschlagen
die opposition spricht von mehreren
tausend toten
[Musik]
das sind freunde von mir ja das hast du
erzählt nienaber können wir zwei haben
bei 1 uhr ist 26-jährige mit umgerechnet
6 franken am tag muss sie die
fünfköpfige familie durchfüttern
die familie der höhere der nothing goes
an sagt chen der klasse der besitzlosen
der gehsteig ist er zu hause die
hygienischen bedingungen sind
katastrophal macht sich sorgen um die
gesundheit ihres sohnes aber sie sieht
keinen ausweg und sagt arme bleibe in
diesem land immer arm viele reiche geben
ihr geld an die nächste generation
weiter wir sind arm aber wir sind
ehrlich wenn sie ihre kunden bedient
denke sie oft dass viele von ihnen durch
korruption und vetternwirtschaft reich
geworden sind sagt sie
am abend lädt mich schnell zu sich nach
hause ein
der 46 jährige will mehr seine frau
vorstellen und seinen kleinen sohn
durch ihn vor einem monat sind die
beiden eltern geworden
zum ersten mal der kleine hat noch
keinen namen
den wert ein astrologe bestimmen wie das
hier üblich ist
ted ist 41 und physikerin ist in einer
regimekritischen familie aufgewachsen
jäger des geschehens leben häufig
isoliert und heiraten darum oft
untereinander
er war lange zeit im gefängnis aber sie
haben immer zu ihm gehalten die
unterstützt was gab ja manchmal gab mir
das weh aber ich bin seine ganze familie
ich muss stark sein shell ist sicher
dass der geheimdienst in weiter
beobachtet
in dieser politischen übergangszeit ist
der geheimdienst sehr aktiv die wände
haben die menschen trauen sich
gegenseitig nicht überall sind spione
als vater wehrte er weiter kämpfen
jetzt erst recht sagt schell
[Musik]
die shwedagon pagode ist das wahrzeichen
bürgers ist super glänzte mondlicht sie
ist mit fast zehn tonnen gold verziert
touristen aus aller welt feiern heute
dass vollmond festival die farben die
dürfte die klänge sind ein rausch der
sinne
[Musik]
zur gleichen zeit in der winzigen
garderobe eines großen hotels mayo bei
bereitet sich auf ihren auftritt für
touristen vor an der universität hatte
kamps studiert die 20 jährige zieht es
auf die bühne
ich bin es gewohnt zu tanzen
vor einem auftritt bin ich nicht so
aufgeregt ich freue mich einfach
mai
ein abend mit traditionellen tänzen das
ist fester bestandteil im programm einer
jeden touristengruppe
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wenn ma yue yue bei nicht auf der bühne
steht arbeitet sie als näherin ihre
chefin hat die new york karriere gemacht
im hippen soho quartier nach der öffnung
kehrte modedesignerin mohammed 2012 nach
burma zurück das label made in myanmar
in ihren kleidern mache sie sehr stolz
moment wirft sorgfältig verarbeitete
kreationen aus erstklassigen stoffen
aber ihre haupteinnahmequelle sind
uniformen für fluglinien hotels und
schulen
[Musik]
sie sieht sich nicht nur als
arbeitgeberin sondern auch als förderin
der jungen frauen
mach es genauso wie auf dem bild wenn du
bei den armen
ruf mich bitte die kehrseite musst du
ausschneiden
es war daher nicht wohl jetzt bitte den
roten stoff und schneide hinzu zu
schneiden
juli ist sehr stolz hier zu arbeiten wo
hamm habe es weit gebracht und von ihr
können sie viel profitieren
ich bin dankbar hier zu arbeiten
warum ist brillant und außergewöhnlich
sie ist mein vorbild
ich hoffe dass für mich weiter mit ihr
arbeite ich auch einmal so gut wäre
die meisten der jungen frauen gehören zu
einer minderheit und haben keine gute
ausbildung
mohorn bezahlt ihnen einen angemessenen
lohn lehrte schreiben und rechnen
die jungen frauen seien die zukunft des
landes sagt [ __ ]
sie gibt ihr wissen weiter an ihrer
schwester und die nachbarin und sprechen
viel miteinander
alle geben das was sie gelernt haben
weiter wenn ich eine junge frau aus
bilde bilde ich das ganze dorf aus eine
person lehrt zehn andere darum arbeite
ich mit frauen im showroom springen die
angestellten auch schon mal als model
ein
die elegante garderobe ist bei
burmesischen geschäftsfrauen sehr
gefragt
die linie mit dem ethno touch ist ja
ausländischen botschaftsangestellte sind
beliebt lebt ihren angestellten vor was
eine starke frau heute in burma
erreichen kann
ich weiß wie man eine firma wird
ich kann einen businessplan erstellen
und ich hoffe dass sie meinem beispiel
folgen und sich eine gute ausbildung
aneignen so dass nicht nur als hobby
betreiben
sie sagt das war schwach gehalten werden
in wahrheit aber sind sie sehr stark und
intelligent und sie verkörpern auch dass
ich bin nicht die beste aber das
wichtigste ist
man sollte nie aufhören zu lernen
von ina auch von meinem fahrer nämlich
dinge von denen ich keine ahnung hatte
ich prüfe jetzt immer kräftig was auf
burger das sind hier schon richten und
2007 revolution gefilmt und die bilder
eingeschickt hat und die bilder sind und
wald und sie anders gemacht und das
schwierig stellung standorte mit große
gefahr braucht aber trotzdem zu achten
und ihren höchsten respekt vor den
journalisten und sehe ich bin zu geben
sie lange gewartet sprechen herr dollar
nein danke für ihre zeit
desolat ist
er sendet der öbb ihre radiosendungen
aus dem exil in norwegen seit vielen
jahren machen sie auch fernsehen zum
jobprofil eines jeden journalisten hier
gehören ein kritischer geist
eigenständiges denken und
furchtlosigkeit es erstaunt mich nicht
dass viele hier schon mehrmals vom
regime verhaftet worden
sie zeigt mir bilder von gestern
studenten demonstrierten dagegen dass
ihre akademische freiheit eingeschränkt
werden soll
die mit den roten armbinden sind von der
regierung angeheuerte schläger zusammen
mit der polizei gehen sie brutal gegen
die demonstranten vor
[Musik]
bis vor ein paar monaten haben sie
proteste toleriert aber jetzt wird es
ihnen zu viel mit der studentin streik
und dem arbeiter streik reagieren heftig
die regierung setzt eine art
schlägertruppen das hat sie in der
geschichte schon öfter gehört
2003 von sun tzu chi zur morgen
versuchten sagten sie es heute heißt es
dasselbe
genau wie 2007 während der fun
revolution es ist nicht die polizei ist
ein schläger drucken angeheuert von der
regierung zeigt den ganzen tag aktuelle
bilder der proteste erst rumänische
staatsfernsehen zeigt zur gleichen zeit
einen belanglosen offiziellen anlass es
gibt ein sprichwort das sagt alles ist
anders aber nichts hat sich verändert
aber schauen sie mich an ich darf wieder
arbeiten nach 25 jahren im exil
das hat sich verändert ich kann in
meiner eigenen arbeit
das ist ein wandel aber die probleme
bleiben unterdrückung und armut viele
themen die wir anprangern
da hat sich nichts verändert die
regierung verweigert dem sender noch
immer eine übertragungs lizenz
democratic voice of burma wird dadurch
indirekt zensuriert in burma kann der
sender nur über satellit empfangen
werden
in ihren sendungen nehmen die
journalisten kein blatt vor den mund
guten tag der berühmten sie zum
editorial talk diese woche diskutieren
wir mit planungs und da ist der
politische kopf des magazins ihrer wade
und kojoten er ist politischer
kommentator
bei der niederschlagung der proteste
haben wir eine junge frau gesehen und
von der polizei misshandelt wurde
die leute wurden geschlagen auch schon
alles wenn die regierung schlägertruppen
einsetzt ist das für die politische
wende im land katastrophe
gemäß der verfassung ist das militär
befugt die führung übernehmen dann
können sie die wahlen verschieben vor
allem um den gebieten der minder unter
dem vorwand der sicherheit dürfen sie
allemal
aber wir wollen nicht zurück in die
dunklen zeiten
wir wollen die politische veränderung
vorantreiben
aber das ist gefährlich hat will nicht
auf einen umbruch warten sondern selber
teil des umbruchs sein sagt er
menschen wie er zeigen auf wie wichtig
die arbeit unabhängiger journalisten ist
für ein demokratisches vor maxi
am samstag schon ihr ganzes leben
gekämpft
ein training im kickboxen dem
nationalsport boomers steht bevor
alonso ist ein star und hat in der
kampfsportart der burmesen schon
unzählige auszeichnungen gewonnen
euro
medway menge die burmesen das kickboxen
der grundsatz des lettres lautet starker
körper aber sanfter geist hage technik
aber friedliche herzen
heute trainiert
denn nachwuchs kickboxen ist in mir mal
eine tradition sportart die apple waren
müssen wenn die jungen an wettkämpfen
teilnehmen können sie geld verdienen von
stadt zu stadt reisen
das ist spannend für sie so nie zeigen
wie man kickbox
[Musik]
das eher schweigsamen
okay es gibt viele menschen aber nur
wenige sind bevor ich damit anfangen
begann ich oft schlägereien aber seitdem
ich boxe nie mehr das ist die richtige
haltung
wir verabschieden uns mit einem
traditionellen netter gruß in london
gibt es ein ganz spezielles 4
es wird lidl india genannt und ist ein
vorgeschmack auf das was wir in der
nächsten folge erwartet
davon rate ich nicht probieren was nicht
beeindruckt hat sind ihr viele
begriffliche mutige manchmal versuche
zur kunstform land mitgestalten vor der
ausreise peter noch in gehe und ich wäre
gern über land reist aber im nordosten
von indien 50 yards ein der ethischen
konflikt und zisterne ausflüge heizhaus
wieder im bundestag
in der nächsten folge lerne ich kann
alle kennen sie hat einen traum und will
unbedingt polizistin werden im kassier
angela zion ahl park treffe ich große
tiere und deren beschützer
eine legendäre eisenbahn bringt mich in
die wohl bekannteste t metropole der
welt
laut schilling
[Musik]
rot grün rot mit globetrotter uns im
fernsehen ist die wahl siebte bis achte
november im kursaal bern fernweh bis die
wunden punkt ch